welcome to another episode of don't get
forked my name is Ryan I'm the club
manager here and this show is about
showing puzzles that all involve Forks
we have contestants come up a lot of
employees and club members will come up
and they'll look at a puzzle and try to
figure out how the best way to not get
forked and just so there's no confusion
about what a fork is a fork is when one
piece attacks two other pieces any piece
can fork so all of our puzzles are
supplied by international master Eric
Rosen so thank you very much for that
and let's go to the board all right
welcome back to round 2 of don't get
forked here with us is Perry Coulson
chess club associate now Perry your goal
in this puzzle is blacks turn to move
okay and you have to figure out what to
do to not get forked to not get four
there might be multiple moves but you
have to figure out the best move to not
get for it to not get long do I have
you'll have 30 seconds okay are you
ready here and turn around three seconds
okay
all right three two one go black to move
right like to move all right so the
board
the forked right well you have to not
get forked okay
[Music]
lots of things going on to the board
first you have to identify with problem
is 20 seconds left by the way is black
to be the best move here you have 10
seconds to pick a move to my castle all
right Kari why can't you castle here oh
because I'm in Czech
you're in check yep so now that we've
established where you're in Czech what
should you do okay not get for it with a
knight I mean fort does a knight Perry
I'm not here to tell you the answer you
got to figure this out you're not get
for it don't get forked will give you an
additional 20 seconds alright so Perry
you moved your knight here to block the
check which is fine move but do you see
that I'm now torquing the king and the
night okay I always thought that a fork
was only available with a night huh
Perry the common misconception okay you
get a spoon for that one forks can be
paid with any piece on the board okay
now I know that now that you know that
what should you have done here instead
to not get for it and you're in check so
you have it you know you
Forked again forth again don't get Forks
all right all right so you have to get
out a check right right so what else can
you do
so clearly blocking is doesn't work
right I guess I have to move my king
okay where's the best place to move your
king and just the king is to be forked I
mean well the king is in chat right so
you have to deal with that you can't
ignore that right the fork is the queen
right okay okay how about this one that
is the correct move good job all right
fine here you go
stinky backspace thank you very much are
you all right thanks for joining us on
don't get forked please like share and
subscribe to all our videos and if you
have any good fork puzzles please send
them to info at st. Louis chess club org
thanks